thank you academy for this student  academy award it is such an honor to  receive it  thank you victoria and jackie for your  great performances thank you holier for  your guidance and your wise words behind  the camera  thank you laura for the great script and  thank you walking ghost film with felix  kevin and wenzel for your trust in this  story and for your guts to make this  movie  thank you filmqueen africa with lidarma  and linda for your support  thank you christine for your wise words  and your guidance along this journey and  thank you university of television and  film munich with professor gruber and  professor marcus rosenmiller for all the  support you gave to us and thank you to  all the people who were a part along  this journey  i hope that adesa  showed you that we have to acknowledge  the things that happened  and this is the first step to get into a  brighter future thank you very much  academy thank you team for all you did  thank you  you